allez mes chéris vous savez une vendredi
on se régale puisqu'elle est là nous et
sandrine sarroche tout avec mon chéri
[Applaudissements]
dupoux saint bernard du jeu ça me fait
beaucoup de peine alors c'est du mimosa
c'est ça ma chaire une saab a menti sur
il a bien fêté son anniversaire ouais ça
va ça va et toi oui moi c'était la
semaine damien team l'appel lancé par le
jour sur la toile ouais bah merde
cadeaux demain est pas a dit donc sida
c'est moi ou il quelque chose plutôt
l'annoncé mois
chez moi c'est quoi ta micha c'est ma
tenue de scène ah oui tu vas faire quoi
c'est ma tenue de scène c'est la tenue
d' affiches c'est que je reprends mon
spectacle le 8 octobre il trop couverte
foutu le rythme est un petit malaise
mais j'aurai mon manteau bah oui je veux
bien
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout ça pour ça non
encore encore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
social et
[Applaudissements]
sandrine est très jolie parce qu'elle a
dit c'est l'eau et l'autre qui dit
encore
trop belle je savais où elle était hier
soir mans alors ça j'avais une semaine
et demie à m'habiller alors je te
présente en comité de soutien écoutez
basé sur des fonds de
retraite étonne pas alors figure toi que
j'ai passé tout l'été sur la plage à
nice avec ce tee shirt et pas un seul
pas paradis donc non par les matches
c'est plus ce que c'était un du coup
j'étais obligée de leur envoyer moi même
la photo de mode non ouais
[Applaudissements]
sebha en tête sur un jeune coach des
jeunes quand ils ont à 16 ans et la très
jeune kate qui dirige la campagne c'est
qu'on aurait dû le faire sans mais paris
match le poids des mots le choc du
maillot
la très jeune coach donc vous l'avez
appris c'est moi c'est moi aussi qui est
trouvée tesco bank campagne ah oui
sahnoun à 2022 c'est fort de chez fort
ça fait kiffer les jeunes ça fait bander
les morts
non mais parce que l'inversé est vrai
aussi alors ah d'accord non non je sais
très bien ce que je dis tu te souviennes
mon coaching de la semaine dernière
n'ont
voté sandrine rousseau ah ouais j'avais
demandé à tout le monde de voter sans
ringo et qu'est ce qui s'est passé et là
vous m'avez écouté la meuf et au
deuxième tour de la primaire écolo c'est
un truc de l'a1 alors à ce stade c
[Applaudissements]
en plus du coaching c'est de la
divination nous sommes l'un des voltaire
c'est avec les petit ruisseau qu'ont
fait les grandes rivières
demandera pas je l'expliqué
savoir mondial bat ça va très bien
expliqué bah oui qu'est ce que tu crois
moi je bosse envoyèrent soir j'ai
regardé la télé il y avait un match vous
le savez un match comptant pour le
championnat de france de boxe catégorie
super relou alors
à mon expérience au rouge
en léger surpoids le punk les calanques
l'insoumis au banc dattiers alias la
république c'est moi de combat de
défaite par ko en irlande jean luc
mélenchon
[Applaudissements]
luc mélenchon qui sera avec nous dans un
score pour débriefer 1 il va nous
attention attention à ma droite à ma
droite enfin mon école
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez le type de montreuil le
napoli ans de l'ouverture italia spa la
baignade c'est son premier combat
professionnel
avec zemmour
[Applaudissements]
m
sans rigoler cher gaza où tu as trou
mais quand même sur montage masque il
faut le trouver ce corps
moi j'adore j'adore la boxe j'étais prêt
j'avais plateau avec le pop corn le
fitzwilliam détox le bol de quinoa tous
âges étaient au taquet normal c'est la
boxe mais à peine ils ont dit bonjour je
ne sais pas pourquoi ça m'a mis ko je me
suis endormie comme un sénateur genre
gérard larcher pendant une intervention
de jean castex et c'est dommage non
c'est dommage parce que un combat comme
ça ça sera pas d'un côté eric zemmour le
candidat qui n'est pas candidat mais qui
est quand même candidat enfin bon voilà
qui veut regarder la france dans les
yeux entre parenthèses il aurait mieux
fait de regarder dans son dos il aurait
vu le photographe éric donc c'est moi
qui disait en 2020 je cite la république
n'est pas exactement la france ça
promettait d'être chaud parce que depuis
2018 on le sait tous la république c'est
qui lui
oui c est mixé joly et mélenchon à qui
on peut peut-être conseillé de prendre
un peu moins la mouche et un peu plus de
projets que non vraiment je regrette
d'avoir raté ça en tout cas cyril moi je
te dis
vraiment rien à craindre non mais c'est
vraiment du petit petit challenge